hello everyone welcome to episode 3 of
idiots and abroad i'm alana that's john
that's jacob and that's rahul which is
correct from my perspective which is the
one that will be published
john where in the world are you right
now
i'm in my childhood bedroom
in san diego in a child's bedroom yes
oh no is that why you have gundams in
the background that's not because you
would push you down at all
listen childhood those are my condoms
and they're precious to me and
they're garbage as well i'd love it if
you'd um john i'd love it if you you'd
sign one and i could i could buy it from
you oh really well i already did sign
one did you see it yeah
here let me if he puts that up we're
gonna have to have a bidding war for it
i think we should i do really like when
someone suggested that i sign it
uh and so i was like like i signed and
sell it i was like sure so i signed it
but i used the wrong pen
um
so as you can see it does not look john
you know what that looks like it looks
like when toy story with andy signing
woody's oh no it's actually dry oh wow
i'm surprised that doesn't come off
huh
well it evaporated
it looks bad
um so john how was the tail end of your
amsterdam trip and do you have things to
catch us up at oh yeah i have some
confessions to make i hope they're horny
uh
well sorta
um so first is we i raised enough money
on stream
uh
two audio listeners jacob's just pulled
out like the biggest bottle of something
what are you what is that
that is the pinkest thing i've ever seen
is that rose abroad specifically it's
snoop dogg
rose and you thought you could just do
that in the background in silence while
john starts talking
with a [ __ ] giant wine glass
my refrigerator is filled with these for
my birthday
i have so much this one
everyone got there and i was like wow
look at all these pink drinks i'm gonna
order my own alcohol yeah
i'm so sorry to interrupt you john i
blame jacob
no no no moderately hawaiian fashions
but that's something well that's
something we also
i'm drinking as well as is tradition
if anyone on this podcast is not
drinking uh they will be
alana rojo
those that's not alcohol so
ralph and i anyways oh along with bruce
and autumn
had a lot of alcohol last night
and
now autumn didn't no what i did not
drink you're right because you spread
that out she did not um
uh have spent the entire day being
hungover so nice actually just relax
[Music]
but it was actually me
because of celebrating
um also for audio listeners john has a
focus puller that just made it really
dramatic cause it racks focus to the
shelf
it's like a convenient everyone's to
look at my condoms
i mean yeah i get that i get that um so
i forced tequila down everyone's throats
uh for celebrating we're all celebrating
different stuff so yes we are
celebrating uh the launch of
rahul's show midnight mass which we will
also get today i was going to ask a lot
about like where it was shot and what
the town is like and all that stuff that
counts as travel but first
job first amsterdam okay i raised enough
money on stream to hire two prostitutes
for two hours
how much is that
that was it was 160 euros times four so
540. that's pretty good
i think man
or
yeah
i love that
did that for you
well here's the thing good cause i
i went did that guy started googling
what yeah yeah no don't worry about it i
was just hiring them for their time
twitch it's just for the time
um we did we were planning to have like
a 20-minute intermission in the middle
uh where i turned the camera and mike
off oh yeah but
what ended up happening was i went
online i found a
various
uh out call agencies out calls where
they come to you rather than them having
a location
uh and for some reason
none of them wanted to appear on camera
uh
so
i did not get
to stream uh with some prostitutes uh
i'm mad happy that you told them and
they were like nah and all's well
all good so you what did you do with the
money did you give it back
i i will be refunding it to people i'm
just very lazy and i don't have ruffles
in america
what go brothels in america oh that's
true i can go to the bunny ranch do do a
bunny ranch or do go to any type of like
suspect-looking massage parlor that
someone for some reason 24 hours the
bunny ranch is like outside of vegas
it's not like it's outside of vegas and
there's laws or something where they can
legally
prostitution so you have heard of that
before
i don't want to g up the mandem but
there was a very famous celebrity who
was married to a very famous socialite i
think they had broken up
uh and he went on a binge at the bunny
ranch oh heart attack
survived but
the bunny ranch was
back in the news cycle oh wow a couple
of years ago
and you were worried that that would g
up the mandem
yeah because you know they're on i
zombie and now it was it was like a
basketball player it was a boss it's you
see i think that actually might be how
i've heard of the bunny ranch is from
that news story yeah does it count as
mandem if he's not a friend of yours
personally
anyone who goes to the bunny ranch is a
friend of mine
hi here's the thing it's it's probably
not an hbo max because hbo max is
tailored towards you know
families and stuff right but when it was
hbo go
they had a show
and it was about the bunny ranch but it
was called like the kitten club or
something like that for some reason
yeah yeah that's like raisins in
in southpaw
but it it was a documentary that where
they followed the people at the ranch
and it was
hilarious because the guy who owned it
he's passed away now and he was also
like a terrible person his name was
dennis hoff and he had this giant
orange bald shaved head
he looked like
an orange wearing clothes it was crazy
and he was always being creepy with the
girls and stuff
it was just great and then there was a
special episode where they all performed
songs
like on a stage what uh yeah so if you
could for real oh my you can find that
somewhere
uh it used to be on hbo now it's
probably not i don't think it i don't
hbo used to have an adult section it was
called cat house
cat house yeah what the hell no whatever
you said
club
is at the moment
which
does not look as nice as i expected it
to look
no it's a brothel alana what were you
expecting me
to be a nice ruffle this guy's head is
huge
yeah oh my goodness it's so brown
if everyone's googling i'm going to give
you how's the musical i'm going to
google
it oh my god it's horrendous
him and his bottom [ __ ] uh performed a
song together what the hell
wow that's wild yeah um
in any case
did you go to a sex show
okay here's the thing you know i've been
very vocal about the fact that uh i have
mental health
uh issues i'm medicated for bipolar yeah
and
i've it's been clear sweet sweet sailing
since i started my meds last year
but i don't know if it was a culmination
of me having to come back to the states
the state of the world uh the fact that
i wasn't able to get escorts
uh
that i was rejected by ask i was yeah i
have money
uh i wouldn't have rejected you
without a camera
um but i i had a bout of depression and
i basically just stayed in bed the last
like
uh four days that i was in town and i
did not
eat a banana out of a woman's snail i
just don't think that that excuse is
good enough
john you are our boy we love you um but
you're off the show
hey
listen if there's anyone out there that
wants to let me eat a banana out of
their vagina and just hit me up in my
dms uh we'll find out i think i could
get banned from youtube for soliciting
comment on this video if you want johnny
a banana
since the last time that we spoke like
other tidbits about amsterdam
um really all i did was i just read
stephen king and i sat at cafes you kept
eating that sausage i kept seeing that
sausage you like oh my god oh
yeah
so those sausages
i learned how to make them they're air
cured salamis
so all i need is a is a sheep intestine
guy that i can get sheep's intestines
from of course
it's a mini fridge oh maybe just come
with air and then that makes sense yeah
and i'm gonna make i'm to start making
them you guys that's for christmas you
guys are going to get aged salamis
what's this why is it going to be an
intestine or is is all sausages made
with intestines
uh i think so roast pretty much
wrapped in plastic or something like
real ones this is just kind of a lot of
meat
i've never asked what the sausage casing
is it's usually well it can't meet pork
beef or poultry oh you mean the casing
itself the casing
is artificial
i mean it might be now but it used to no
you're right it is
traditionally made from intestine but
sometimes now made from synthetic
materials oh my god that's not as fun
but so you
feed them through and the trick is that
it's a three percent salt ratio so
whatever your meat weighs
three percent of that you put in salt
and that prevents bad bacteria from
growing but allows good bacteria to grow
and then you just hang them in a fridge
for 10 weeks and then they uh
when you use your twitch money to hire a
prostitute and she comes and grabs some
water from the fridge and sees you
hanging meats
you're going to look like a [ __ ]
serial killer
no i'll look very cultured
one of the other you'll have the she'll
say wow this one's on the house
my house is or the [ __ ]
oh my well that's awesome you learned
how to make sausages we'll take that and
then you can
out of
five what would you rate korea
korea three out of five what would you
rate amsterdam
10 out of five whoa that's a huge
but korea i've already spoken about it
was circumstantial i'm sure it would
have been better
if i had a
guide or something or you know an asian
wife or something
wasn't doug
yeah but doug
listen i couldn't spend every waking
moment with doug yeah
oh it's just too much
friend of the show doug shout out to
doug
you weren't there you were there to just
like live there you didn't want to like
see the sights and stuff you just wanted
yeah yeah it's a different thing you
want to be there and eat food and stuff
tourism is different so what's the plan
now john and i'm asking this because the
people are asking for the record we have
no intentions of stopping the show
but what's your travel plan going
forward
um i'm going to kansas city for a month
next uh in october
uh and then
i'm looking for different places
uh that basically the parameters are
cheap rent
fast internet
kansas city
because it comes up on google
when i go i literally googled
cheap rent
fast internet in the united states and
kansas city came up as number one
because they were like the they were the
inaugural or whatever city for google
fiber the founding city
yeah yeah yeah
and right on the border of missouri and
kansas huh yeah there's there's both
sides jacob come visit you fight
you can come visit me because guess what
for nine hundred dollars you can get a
three bedroom house with like a front
and back lawn good what gravy yeah
uh so that's why i'm looking for places
with fast internet and cheap print
because i'm gonna jump out the window
yeah
imagine if that's how much the rent is
imagine how much the escorts are
exactly
this looks beautiful dude they love that
much elana it has to scale because when
you're when when someone puts a price
you could go oh my god that's more than
rent
if i were an escort i would charge more
than the rent of a three give you an
escort
i would charge more than nine hundred
dollars
would you do you think they'd be like i
don't think
you're like
uh don't quit your day job
yeah i don't feel like i'm cut out for
it
wouldn't make any money i'd be great
i've actually thought about
maybe wearing a mask and being a being a
chatterbait
um
i think it was like when he was a fair
bit younger and he has like mostly very
positive stories about it like seem to
really enjoy it yeah but it did
sometimes uh affect his relationships
afterwards in terms of
people performing a way that he
like he thought that people wanted
things to be recorded or wanted things
to be public or like he people made
assumptions about him sexually based on
the fact that he had
not necessarily correct and they were
always like trying to live up to this
thing of like oh you used to work in
that industry i need to be edgy enough
to to be right for you
yeah i have that problem yeah yeah i
hear that right
women always try to get really
edgy with me
yeah peanut butter jelly
no cameras
i just i was just reminded of something
my brother-in-law who's a a learned
doctor
back in back in london uh called me to
be like uh oh during my commute i
started listening to the idiots and
abroad podcast oh really yeah
and he said uh john is the clear
standout he cracks me up he's so funny
and i was like
okay
you know that your brother-in-law i.e me
is an attention seeker and if i don't
feel like i'm center of attention or the
best at anything i don't want to do it
no more so i'm announcing my retirement
we did send to the show around john and
we will get to you rahul okay midnight
mass happened
we'll get there
but for now john the plan is places with
cheap rent and
internet
i do have a story from when i was
leaving
oh yeah yeah yeah we should we can go to
the rocky mountains let's block our
freshmen let's vlog like a travel guy
travel show let's do it
road trip
i don't know she's our famous friend as
we say is tara
everybody she's also the toughest out of
all of us so if we get any [ __ ] that's
why tara should be there because none of
us can handle herself she's sure
remember when we taught a road man
she'll beat me up oh no
she's much better of doing road man
stuff than i am it's always better
retaining stuff than you guys
every time she's with us i'm like she's
gonna show me up every time because you
were so worried that your friends
thought you were too cool
because we're all just like whoa jacob
this cool road man guy and then tara
shows up and it just brings you down and
not sheena i know if she sees me
drinking this snoop dogg wine then she's
gonna it's gonna become an episode did
she buy it for you no this is from the
willems's actually no way
that's amazing they know what i like
yeah for the for the audience we were
all driving i remember maybe it was big
bear and i think we were grabbing some
coffee and i had noticed that jacob
at his driving position
is
extremely close to the steering wheel
hands 11 and 2. i guess
and he also looks down the end of his
nose as he drives
and it i it [ __ ] destroyed me because
i'd never been in a car with jacob
before so i taught him
the road man thing which is you know the
the kind of like bad boy london thing
yeah there you go
nearly fell off his chest
and as you can see
jacob hasn't taken to the road man and
we were teaching him that's all right he
did get his lean but we were teaching
him like you know
about the mandem and you know certain
slang and stuff from there's that song
that goes gun lean
but
jacob was having difficulty
uh learning it and what we didn't notice
was tara within 30 seconds picked it all
up immediately
she was also going to road my life she
was like oh my god pulling out
edgy jokes that we weren't completely
okay i had a question about that because
every time i've played jack box it's how
quickly
uh like maximum offense can we get
because that's we're all trying to
one-up each other
i don't play i would like to see oh
really i would like to see an amish
family or like a like a very
conservative christian family play and
see what they do
i i feel like it would be angela in in
the u.s office when she was doing mad
libs oh yeah yeah i mean i love
experience that like like you know like
like the game like apples to apples it's
not it's like
playing that with family and stuff
it's not even that i was being
like edgy or anything it's that i would
think i would try to make like a joke
out of something
and just try to like make it funny for
somebody but then they'll see it they're
like that doesn't make any sense for
this game
i'm really bad at it and then i don't
care but that's very good
it'd probably be kind of like that it's
like it's it's wholesome yeah it's
boring
no i feel like we did this when we were
picked by that like i always try to do
in-jokes so things that the people in
the room will understand and oh yeah
every time that i've ever played jack
box when rahul has been around with
whatever group of people people always
make eye zombie jokes that's not
just always an a zombie joke i remember
uh there was one time we were playing
with i think it was
bruce elise and james yeah yeah and
there was like what is written on the
toilet paper in the stall or something
and it was like i zombie and
almost everyone had denied it was like a
different reference to i zombie in some
way and then i think that's the most fun
way to play it it's like just make it
about your friends yeah and uh and dunk
on the cw
yeah we've we talked about it on the
last one but this one was also drawn
naked pictures of jacob yes in various
positions of vulnerability which i
really want to turn i think we spoke
about this before into some kind of
merch we'll figure it out one of john's
one of john's drawings of jacob oh i can
draw a lot of jacobs i want one image
and i don't know which one of us can do
it but i want to commission a t-shirt
just for me that won't be merch but i'm
sure audiences will i want a picture of
john's face with the glasses on and i
want the words i'm going to make you
kern
[Laughter]
around l.a i don't think i can sell that
but
that's just for ruffles just for me i
want to rock that yeah
john left uh on my we have like a little
white board next to our front door and
john drew a great little it's like grogu
but it's the jacob style with little
chubby cheeks and the hair
no [ __ ]
he can't draw yeah
it's great
um so john you have some stories about
leaving
i do
uh so
flying to korea flying to the
netherlands i did all my research here's
all the paperwork you'll need here's all
the things you'll need to do
uh and i was so good about it i had no
troubles
uh getting into those places but then on
my way home i was like it's america and
i'm vaccinated that's all i'm good i'm
going home
uh and then when i got there to check in
she was like okay do you have your
vaccination and i showed her and she's
like all right do you have your negative
uh coveted test
and i was like nope i'm vaccinated she's
like yeah
you need that i was like but i'm an
american
you still need it you especially need it
irrelevant yeah for all of our american
audiences listening uh that's not
doesn't work anymore
the i'm an american things it just
doesn't work
um
so i was like okay luckily i got there
like three hours early and i was like do
you guys have a testing place here she's
like yeah uh you just go
this way that way that way this way i
was like okay
and she let me leave all my bags
uh because they're very heavy i think
i've talked about that as i packed way
too much for the trip
um and so i like sped walked speed i
like sped walk it's peg speed walked
sporting um no it i don't think it is
hastily ventured
speedy walked
uh
and i finally found the place i was
running around uh one lady
uh as i was like speed panic walking by
she went hey
i went oh hey and she handed me
something i looked down and it was kiwi
scented hand lotion
and i was like huge win
yeah and she's like do you want to buy
some lotion i was like do you know where
the covet testing place is
she's like uh it's that way
um but so i get there they walk me over
to some hotel and i get there i'm
filling everything out and it says
uh what's your passport number and i tap
my i tap my pocket and i go
oh god i left it with the check-in
people
so
then i had to sprint back because i was
running out of time
so with my backpack i would sprint for
like 10 feet and then speed walk
for like five minutes and then sprint
um
and then i got back and i look the booth
is empty there's nothing there there's
no luggage and i was like
what the [ __ ] and then i hear hey and i
look over and i guess they're on a break
or something because they were all
crowded around the same little booth
and they had my stuff and i run over and
she she just holds out my passport
because she knew exactly what i needed
so i grab it and i run back
drenched in sweat being like
i got my passport now um and she did the
test and then i got back i got through
but it was like
everything had been smooth sailing
up until
the moment i was leaving yeah um wait
how long did it take to get your test
result
20 minutes yeah the ones at the
airport's really fast oh wow okay cool i
had something like this happen twice so
when i was going to australia
the company that i paid for um to get my
cover test within 24 hours did not
deliver it within 25 oh yeah so you
remember the instagram stories where you
called them out yeah they were very
upset with me like i wouldn't have even
doubled down i would have deleted it if
they weren't so [ __ ] rude like they
were terrible about their responses to
me
um so i didn't get it in time so i was
waiting at the check-in desk like
explaining it to the person and i was
like i'm just it might come through any
minute like i had called and they said
i'd get it before 9pm and i'm sitting
there and time's ticking away and
eventually they're like you can't check
into the flight we can't let you on the
plane so i had to push it thankfully was
able to push it a day um and because i
booked it through a flight agency i
actually didn't have to pay the change
fee which was awesome
and then on the way back on my flight to
get back well to technically get to
nicaragua rather than back to la uh
nicaragua
sorry um it is but i'm also not gonna do
that but that's fine let's not play that
game um
that one the word is just too close for
san diego
oh okay yeah that's fair yeah
uh
the there was some kind of issue
getting on the flight which it was to
stop over in hawaii so the the leg to
hawaii
basically the flight got delayed twice
and for some reason air traffic control
had like recorded it as though it had
already taken off before we had taken
off
so
the
system no longer worked and they
couldn't check in any of our passports
so all of the passengers for this flight
16 of us or something were sitting there
trying to check in but it would reject
every single passport we had
and so we were just sitting there for
about three hours trying to get on the
plane and couldn't because it just
couldn't check us in and we were like
why can't you just call somebody to fix
this and they're like it's super
complicated we can't just like there's
no button
for this so it was one of the strangest
experiences where they were like you
guys want to go get food just like head
down to the food court and we'll let you
leave your bags here stop laughing at
jacob because he's pouring himself a
drink of his snoop dogg wine it's
perfectly normal i don't understand what
else you would expect
it's completely standard it's in
character i'm [ __ ] obsessed with
jacob everything he does just gets me
he's just so on brand you know
it smells like snoop if you were a
character
you would win
an award the commitment that every
character choice is perfect
sorry alone it's incredible
so yeah we eventually got on the flight
and everyone was like what's the takeoff
time but because this whole thing was
such a [ __ ] i didn't have one so
my mom was like when's your takeoff time
like we don't actually have one it's
just whenever we all get on the plane
so we didn't know when we were landing
we're gonna sound like world war z or
something really you know when you look
at the planes on the runway and they're
like what are we doing when are we going
we're like when when do we stop over in
hawaii or what time am i going to land
in l.a because i actually had tickets to
see something in la i was getting off
the plane for that one day before going
to nicaragua um that didn't work but at
no point was i like told when i was
going to land it was so unorganized and
bizarre and i was worried about the
nicaragua part but that [ __ ] flight
was just like it was on fire
very strange experiences sounds horribly
strange no one has that [ __ ] figured out
when i was in frankfurt because i flew
from amsterdam to frankfurt and there's
frankfurt to seattle
i get to the
to the terminal and there's like four
different lines everyone's panicking
uh and i and i asked them at the line i
was like what's going on and they're
like oh we're checking in and i was like
i already did that so i sat down i was
like wait maybe something is wrong here
so i got up
and they're like yeah we're checking in
but we need to check in again or
something i was like okay
so i was standing in line
and then at one point my my line just
dissipated and i was like what happened
and they're like it was the wrong line
oh
okay
um
eventually it like every i don't know if
everyone got on the plane i got on the
plane but i don't know if everyone got
on the plane because it was just go
crazy up until we left but the whole
time everyone was panicking there's this
lady on the intercom going uh if anybody
wants to upgrade come on up to the front
oh
yeah but here's the thing it was half
off
and so i'd already bought my ticket like
a month and a half ago so that money was
gone
and it was only 300 bucks to upgrade to
business class is this the international
flight this is frankfurt to
yeah this is like the
10 11 hour flight the one that matters
you've got to do that 300 bucks
yeah exactly i was like i've never done
it i've never done first class i'm gonna
be sitting there for 10 11 hours i got
to do it
it
it's incredible it's crazy yeah it's
like the classist
i want to be super privileged right now
i'll never pay for business
first class any of that stuff like if
work usually provides it for work trips
the one time i did was i was in new york
uh doing press for izombie the day
actually
when i don't know if anyone remembers
this a terrorist
uh
ran over people in times square
oh my gosh did you do you remember that
thing and my manager kimberlyn
she had just left the event after taking
care of me and you know you know
whatever and headed in that direction
and then
we just found out so she was there when
that happened like with oh my god feet
or yards or something it was a mad close
call
and the whole city shut down and we had
a flight that day and i had to be in
london the next morning for a convention
and so the whole city was shut down we
were trying to get out the traffic so by
the time i arrived at the airport
obviously it was it was it was it was
difficult to kind of get out of the city
anyway as i approached the desk a lady
comes up to me and she's like sir would
you like to upgrade to upper class it
was virgin
and i was like how much and she said a
thousand dollars and i was like
but i really needed to be in london the
next morning
and i had accepted that i would appear
at this convention knackered
so
what does knackered mean he always
daggers jacob drink it again it's the
way he lifted it he went
it's so sophisticated how else am i
supposed to drink snoop dogg's rose
actually this is perfect
jacob you would have fit in in upper
class yeah
i said yeah i said yeah because i was
like [ __ ] it i want the flatbed i don't
care what it is i want the flatbed
so anyway
i go on and i'd never done upperclass
before
all the people there
middle-aged kind of business folk they
all
like took something that was being
handed out by the hostess like what the
[ __ ] is this and they all disappeared
and came back in pajamas
what all of them
it was like overgrown babies they all
had these like silk pajamas that and i
was like what the [ __ ]
and they're like like a 50 year old guy
like silver fox and he's now just in
oversized sort of pajamas
and i was like oh [ __ ] it when in rome
right
so i didn't just strip down right next
to your chair
yeah i didn't go into a bathroom
i have no class but um it was it was and
then like the best thing ever on this
flight
and nothing's ever sort of come close to
it was
uh the the air host des
approached again and said he was like
you know do you want anything from the
menu and i was like no i'm i'm good that
nothing there tickled my fancy and she
was like are you sure we the chef can't
prepare you something i said
and i was like well i'll tell you what
uh
i would love
an english breakfast and she was like
can do what
really an hour went by came back
sausages eggs bacon beans on cutlery
tomato no i i said went to that [ __ ]
what i don't have any of that
i don't know and i just sat there in
this flatbed and was just i had a full
english and she was like let us know
when you're ready to go to bed and then
you let them know this is the overgrown
baby thing and everyone had to do this
you're not allowed yourself to turn the
flatbed into the bed
right the seat people probably hurt
themselves lose their phones whatever
yeah they're so rich they don't
understand like i've never done this
before i don't know how to turn convert
chair into bed um
so you press a button and then they
arrive you stand up next to them like
i don't know a child watching your dad
sort of like
help you
and they flip it turn it put a little
chocolate on your thing and they go
there you go and then you just climb in
and it's it's [ __ ] weird man you just
you feel like a child for most of you
did they take you in
it's not no they didn't do the thing but
it was it was a turnover service type
thing like a hotel wow
and it's the only time because i don't
sleep on flights i find it really
difficult
it's one of the only times i can count
on one hand that i uh
slept
um and it was worth it i mean like it's
a [ __ ] extortionate price but for you
know because i like i said business
people are the people that make sense
for i mean i've never done it um and i
mean i also suck at it but the one time
that i got upgraded to first class
was a flight from seattle to san
francisco which is like a [ __ ] hour
i was like
cool now's the time you picked up great
me united thank you for that they knew
what they was doing they weren't giving
you they were like yeah great news um
you owe us one
that's why i was working for xbox one
time they flew me from
australia to
hong kong to germany for a games call
and they had paid for me to have economy
plus so i had a little bit of extra
seating because it takes you like 30
hours to get there you work for three
days straight 30 hours back it's awful
uh but for some reason the airline
booked it out so they gave me cash in
hand as i was boarding the flight they
were like yeah it's sold out even though
you bought this ticket so here's some
cash so they paid you the difference in
cash so they just gave me money
right and took my flight away and i was
like did you tell bill
i did not that's a microsoft joke billy
microsoft no i did in fact keep the cash
actually which is kind of shady i'm
being honest there's probably should
have been somebody i'm rep i'm tweeting
that right now can i can i flex my
connection
on your new flight
well did that feel worth it on the new
flight is happening about dude it was
kind of it was it was ridiculous okay so
they
they're like do you want beef or salmon
and i said i'll take salmon
and then 20 minutes later they brought
me out this tray that had salmon on it
it was like salmon crackers
and then she came around with this
basket full of like 12 different kinds
of bread yeah
and i so i took two of them and the guy
next to me was like what was this
this was the one
it was condor which i'd never heard of
um
and uh and so they brought me that and i
ate it i was like oh man that was
filling i'm full that was really good
and then they took him away and then
they brought me out this giant plate
with like a thick-ass thing of salmon
and peas
and like mashed potatoes i was like what
the [ __ ] so i ate that and they brought
me more bread and soy two more pieces of
bread this is how they kiss i'm not
gonna deny bread
and then
they brought out a dessert which was
this like pink disc thing i think it was
cheesecake or something what did flight
see you boys going on i know it was and
it was on top of like a frozen cookie or
something
and i was in with with like mink cut up
mango jelly next to it oh my gosh nice
and so i was like oh i was trying to eat
that and i didn't finish it and then as
she was taking it away i was like man
ma'am she's like yes i was like that's
all the food for now right like are you
bringing out more food you have to eat
it
yeah john you're not obligated for it
yeah and she's like no that's it i was
like oh thank god
did you pass out
uh oh yeah so i had i had a chair that
had like 15 different buttons it's one
of those ones where it has a picture a
side picture of a chair and there's
different angles like arrows and stuff
different
things but it also had different like
presets and so the laying down you'd
press it and it
it was like it reminded me of like a
shitty
like carnival ride or something because
you'd hold the button down and you'd be
like
different part of your body was moving
at one time and sometimes it would catch
and it was like you're slowly going down
and anytime you wanted to adjust it like
you'd hit the button and be like
very peaceful um yeah
uh so i was great i watched uh one thing
i love about planes is that you can
watch like six movies at the same time
if you have an aisle seat yeah because
you're watching your movie oh yeah the
guy you got no sound no i watch other
people's movies on planes all the
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah
every star wars
the guy he watched uh
episode nine whatever the [ __ ] that's
called
rogue one
uh
another yeah star wars stops after
episode six you idiot
oh sorry we allow rogue one
well i slept through both eight and nine
so i love them because they were like 30
minutes for me somehow
palpatine returned
really
i didn't catch that part
it's a quote that's a direct quote from
the movie
um another guy was watching like uh king
kong i watched uh
soul
oh yeah yeah
i thought it was about jazz music
there were like two songs in it
just running around it's like a weird
little it was tina fey like a weird
little cherub yeah
tina what
i liked it but i i was expecting like a
lot more music
yeah like music lala land had more jazz
in it than sold it sure yeah
yeah anyways it was a fun flight uh the
perfect i had the perfect guy next to me
too because he didn't want anything to
[ __ ] do with me
uh
so that was great
um there's this one one flight that i
feel like i always think about was um
again a gamescom flight with a bunch of
people at ign and brian altano who's one
of the hosts at ign had this guy sitting
next to him i don't know what country he
was from but anytime any person would
walk past any
person who worked on the plane
um he would always stop them and go
apple juice
every single time i'd be like i will
have one apple juice
apple juice and so brian's just sitting
next to this apple juice serial killer
he was just repeatedly demanding it i
think he even buzzed for it as well and
so ever after that anytime anyone orders
apple juice on a flight i'm like is it
him is it the action
is he returning so random i can kind of
empathize with him because you're like
oh i'll get a water and they bring you
out a shot glass yeah and they say it's
for your contact lenses
i'm like can i get like a like a like a
flask or like a giant
pitcher
i always go can i can i flex yes when
you guys do your flex me who's only been
this year flew on a private jet
this oh whoa
oh
jacob
we're all flexing this is useless for
the audio it's actually okay everyone's
flexing all right uh we actually don't
have many audio listeners the show is
like and now jacob
fortunately video so it works out pretty
well
because they love looking at jacob's oh
jacob's taking these dicks are you
opening your dick
are you gonna do that oh no this is
reaching for this
[Laughter]
um
yeah this year i flew on a private jet
and
i was super excited i've never done it
before it was uh production had arranged
it because of covid
uh i feel like it was january or
something and and it was the only way
that they could get it approved for
travel for this for the cast and and a
few others so
they hired two you almost said for the
stars
for the artists
um for the thespians uh
so
we get like so you go we was we left
from burbank and you know like
what the part that i thought was amazing
like as an experience was pretty much
entering this airport
and having your luggage taken away from
you
and just walk onto the runway like it
was a it's a wonderful it's just like
you just go on and then you go and the
passport you don't do anything
at all
no security no passport
they like are you thinking they've
already pre-checked or something along
those lines like i think they looked at
the passport but that was that they've
done it twice and they only need a state
id for it i think yeah
so damn but here's the thing i had never
done before right because i didn't enjoy
the flight in fact i hated it
we were on a tiny tiny private jet
and
everyone filled up and obviously i was
being a gent so like after you know
after you know after you loving it after
you yeah yeah now i love going going
sugar tits after you
and then
wait yeah
i got on and realized the only seat left
was facing everyone with my back to the
[ __ ]
and i'm a nervous flyer and i was like i
don't think in my life i've
taken off backwards right
so my heart rate starts going my anxiety
is kicking off but everyone that
produced the cast is looking at my face
so i was like
you got to be the object you got to be
the air hostess now right you got to be
the flight attendant sorry that's that's
the correct term
you got to be a flight attendant if we
start rumbling or turbulence i can't go
like i have to be a
beacon of strength absolutely right and
i and i fully felt that
and i'm not i hate flying
so i strap in and then
we start right and it's like
it starts speeding up and then as it
started lifting up i felt all the blood
rushed like and i was like oh god
i felt like i was facing
so i was like but i'm just trying so
hard to just like look cool yeah does it
push you forward yeah are you being
pulled out of your seat it was like it
felt like my it was a really weird thing
because you're obviously you're you feel
this right when you're
not like but facing the other way
i don't know it feels like it it felt
like my blood was pushing this way while
i was forcing myself back because
yeah it was the g's
but the thing was the flight
because it was a small
private jet whatever the a jet i don't
know what it is
um
you've i felt
everything ever oh yeah single bump
everything yeah you're much more
susceptible to turbulence
and then most and every article about
actor or sports personality die in
private jet like went through my mind i
was like this is how you do it eat the
rich this is it this i'm dead i'm a dead
man i'm going to be a a
couple helicopters
like travis barker
everybody is looking at you and you're
just wide-eyed dripping with sweat
you're going to play a cool place
apple juice
but yeah so that yeah the whole it was
just a horrible
like
it was cool it was night but it wasn't
enjoyable like it was just terrifying
being backward and then when it starts
and it's like that and i'm facing
everyone and i'm just like you know and
i also had a mask on right at the moment
you know like [ __ ] bane
like
you know the fire rises
crashing this plane
it would be extremely painful
for you
yeah
so
that sounds yeah hard
yeah especially um as a man of color
like
dude i i wouldn't even be able to do
that i can't ride on a train or a bus or
anything because they always have those
backwards seats on different people
yeah if i do that it's just like oh yeah
yeah i can't do it i have trouble in uh
long car trips and and i was having
trouble when we drove back from vegas it
was a point where i just sat up oh yeah
and i was like oh god and i think you
asked me a question or several questions
jacob and i was just going to have a
conversation and then you were just they
usually just like
you might need to stop the car i was
like i don't know i have a very good
vomit meter i know if i'm going to vomit
because my mouth gets sweet
you've done it rahul you finally pulled
the focus you've finally done it wait
elana isn't it just a straight road for
like 300 miles yeah
pretty much
doesn't look good it's just any kind of
motion if i'm not looking directly ahead
i like i have some
it's real bad
um but we do have uh more travel stories
to get into
rahul
yeah technically this week it's this
week but we'll be this published in two
weeks
um midnight mass came out a few weeks
ago as of this published date
congratulations we all but technically
we really liked it
it came out yesterday no
where else it was two days ago two days
ago two days ago yeah um yeah
yeah it came out and obviously um i
gave i showed you a lot my screen is we
may have all seen it early yes yes are
we gonna say that guys i don't think it
matters now oh i know i told you i told
them i told them i told them but i i
made the tweet on friday saying i can't
wait to watch this
it's all right like
we're all we're all friends and family
like you know my manager obviously would
has used my code like people will watch
it but it's still watermelon and i take
responsibility i streamed the whole
thing on twitch
whoops
oh my god rahul the rose strikes again
in the top 10 on netflix top 10 in the
us
you're right behind melissa mccarthy
wait where are we in the top ten number
three i wouldn't be surprised
for ages you'll be there for a long time
yeah uh i found that squad
mike let me told me that we've trended
four times in the past 24 hours 48 hours
either his name or
i don't know maybe u.s trending or
whatever but
it just keeps re-trending um oh wow cool
it's been it's been amazing man like
obviously
um i know you guys were were super happy
with it and
uh jacob's a former altar boy
oh my god which which was i mean john
was a very religious upbringing as well
right yeah we won't spoil it by the way
on this podcast we weren't expecting any
spoilers yeah uh what can i give my
non-spoiler review
yeah man of course
nah no never mind
and that's the review
my bread and butter my well not my bread
and butter because that's talent my
favorite [ __ ]
my pb and j's because i love pb and j's
i love people
butter banana of
like a grilled cheese but it's a peanut
butter banana it's amazing it is amazing
really yeah i love pb and j i've never
had one you should try pb and banana
that's bananas best flavor
it's the best flavor i had a lot of
those when i was growing up yeah we
didn't we didn't do pb j in australia
yeah same in the uk my first pb j was
was was when i came out i love it it's
incredible mostly
you could put beans on a [ __ ]
sandwich yeah stupid you shut the
british [ __ ]
staple anyways
uh my favorite stuff is when it's that
eerie
uh eerie show where it's like
like is there something supernatural
going on i don't know yeah yeah have you
seen the terror no but i love super
eight for that reason
uh-huh
i was i was telling rahul that uh
initially i got very like vibe wise
very much like the terror which season
one of that is like one of my favorite
uh series
now it's it's been yeah the terror it's
been replaced by midnight mass
let me tell you
yeah i mean also in the end at the very
in the last episode yeah
that was crazy [ __ ]
yeah
jacob yeah how did you feel about it as
foam or ultraboy yeah i mean
like i grew up like catholic like just
surrounded by catholic stuff
and with catholicism being like the
faith specifically represented in the
show
so much of it was like
just so
like precise
and was hitting all these specific like
notes like i was reading a bunch of like
tweets about the show from other people
that were catholic like oh my god this
is like
putting me right back in church and it's
freaking me out
and stuff like when i was telling i went
to a wedding over the weekend with a lot
of like my
currently catholic friends i'm like
y'all gotta watch this show
it'll hit you real hard
just watch it anytime anytime like when
they were doing mass
um
and the bells from you know the older
boy rings the bells at certain points
jacob you could see his muscle memory
just before it was he knew just without
first time show you i saw jacob go
like he was going along
like like i think there was one point
where
like the
priest was
like
doing the sacrament of the eucharist and
you know he was saying all these words
and i was looking at rahul just like
saying the words to him
yeah and i hadn't seen the show before
so and it was and it was a it was a
great way to experience it with jacob
looking in my eyes eye contact
over his snoop dogg wine
um but rahul it seems like the muslim
community's had a very positive reaction
to it as well which is awesome
uh religions across the board yeah seem
to have responded really positively
yeah we
i guess i mean no matter what you you
always want to like
you want to do right by people and when
i first i was really scared to do this
role because
there are so many
things that we deal with here like are
we going to upset catholics you know
like how is our portrayal of of this
character going to be received and like
i was lucky because
i think i've spoken about him before and
i know you guys have met or know of him
in some ways but my best friend in the
whole world
beau uh his full name is mohammed bowie
he like he's in a lot of my stories i
think did i tell once
do you ever talk about him cracking his
head open and the blood oh yeah we did
that right
that was last episode right that's bo
right
so when
mike
i was on blind he oh and you know we had
a meeting and he offered me the the role
as soon as i took it
i called beau to be like yo i've got
this character
um i'm gonna be you know i'm i'm playing
a muslim
can you help me can like can we start
and so we would just talk talk for hours
and he was like about his faith and i
grew up around it anyway so obviously i
already had a good understanding of it
and what he had been through two of your
really close friends are muslim right
yeah mohammed and muhammad before that
like you
i've had this conversation with with uh
another muslim friend that
you will try to like not even swear
in your conversations with them during
ramadan yeah oh yeah yeah like i'm an
atheist but and and so is aaron we're a
group of four friends right aaron's
white dude from from the uk just
mayonnaise um
i love making fun of aaron
but
even aaron who's an atheist um during
ramadan when we were kids
um
the boys because of where ramadan was
and and they obviously break fast
at
sunset
it usually fell around like i think at
this time when we were at school
based on the calendar it was happening
around about 4 p.m i want to say
um
and we obviously finished school at 3
15. you go to the you know the
show you finish school at 3 15 and you
think that that's normal
3 15 p.m why is 3 150 is that not normal
it's just stormy i feel like no it's
three and then 15 minutes was form
registration
we did ours was at 3 45.
it was like a post registration
every school is different i want to make
the rules
for saying obviously
obviously to brits
well depends on the school
but anyway
like as soon as school finished whatever
you know your pocket money we would like
head straight to a grocery store or
whatever and a news agents and grab like
coke and dr pepper and
cola bottles whatever the hell we wanted
and we'd be starving at that point yeah
and lunch was like 11 a.m
and
we'd wait and observe fast with the boys
we're like we won't eat until you can
break fast so we would just chill
like outside fighting with each other
yeah
but we would just wait and then when it
was time they were like cool and then we
tuck into our things together so like we
would you would you buy everything and
just set it there and then just stay
until sunset yeah they did it too they'd
know what they were going to break their
fast with so it was just and that's us
as kids excited about it yeah and that's
just us his kids and you know we're edgy
you know kids are trying to be edgy and
and we would always have digs at each
other about our heritages or our race or
mucking around like there was always
that but
when it mattered
like we were we were like i don't know
there was just this mad respect anyway
so
um
cut to 2019
you know me and bo are now in our early
34 at the time and and i so i hit him up
and i was like brother what do i do
and the main question i asked him was i
was like
when you when we were kids what did you
want to see from the muslim hero guy or
you know the brown dude in a show and
that's what we were
talking about and then mike found out
like in january because we weren't even
going to film until the summer or
whatever march so
he found out that i had you know about
my relationship to bo and he was like
hey can i um can i send him the scripts
and can we like can i consult with him
um and they they did and then they
started
going through the scripts together this
is my best friend i've known since
elementary school
and i'm being ceced into emails between
him and and mike and they're discussing
certain things and does this work and
what do you think and
and
i was emotional anyway and and then
anyway so this is a very long-winded
serious role answer which i i'll go back
to being a dick in a minute but
you know coming all of that work that we
put in to come back and then when the
show dropped on twitter
uh
to see people tweet me from the
community
being like this is some of the best
muslim representation we've ever had in
western media
i beau's not on twitter so i was
screenshotting it and i was like look
what you did for your community brother
like look look what you've done this is
an american these are white americans
going
what they believe in jesus too there's
similarities with like
i don't even know it hasn't you know you
don't see that in a prominent show like
this
um so
everything that i get on twitter it's
it's for beau and i'm just he's not dead
but i dedicated to
this to the memory of mohammed bowie so
thanks mohammed my dad he just keeps
asking if i can cast him as a dragon in
god of war
um not that one even necessarily exists
he just keeps asking if he can be a
dragon and his audition aussie dragon
yes he's very aussie because my attacker
in my scales
very australian sometimes if he visits
here i have to translate what he's
saying
because he doesn't cut back on any of
his
lingo he doesn't cut back on any of the
slang so even like in a taxi or an uber
full of aussie using all the aussie
sayings and they're like like what give
an example um i'm not here to [ __ ]
spiders [ __ ] spiders mate so then you
have to translate what that means like
he's a true blue like he'll say just
aussie [ __ ] that nobody understands
doesn't care he makes friends so easily
but yeah he's just like why won't you
cost me as a dragon like i don't know
that i have the power to do that or that
it fits in the norse realm but how would
the internet like you know one thing i
do know about
gamers
is they're mad level-headed and very
calm super chill yeah
uh and forgiving how would they feel if
they were playing a god of war or
something and the dragon was like
you know my fire's coming out my nozzles
i guess that's how you say nostrils or
whatever
um i actually think that would be fine
because my dad is white
oh okay
it's an acceptance
boom guys
i i kind of zoned out there i've just
been staring at this picture of melissa
mccarthy holding a bird what's the
melissa
can you stop giving her engagement so we
can move to number one hey you are in
front of my little pony the movie so
that's you draw congratulations just be
proud this is all that like that's all
that mike flanagan wanted
we want to [ __ ] take out my little
pony
i guess i guess the reason we were going
to talk about midnight yeah that's a
little bit crocket island which is
behind crockett island is the the place
where it's set and uh i wanted to ask
about like what crockett island is is it
real do you actually go there like was
it built like if we're talking about
travel what is rocket island that's in
the show
so firstly
crockett island i believe
is based or at least inspired by a real
island in america called tangiers island
i go if you guys want to google as i go
alongside i don't remember a lot of this
this is like years ago
tangiers island or something like that
tangia island in virginia there you go
that's the one
that's what took the kind of tangerine
island that's the one that's moon
well population was only 727.
yeah oh it's the one that's sinking
yeah i've seen videos oh no
yeah
since the 1850s
yeah and one of the things that's
happened is because of the sinking
because of the sinking
um
a lot of the dead bodies the skeletons
rise to the surface in their front yards
and stuff because it's
bringing stuff up to the surface this is
tangier's island also one of the things
i remember henry was telling me henry
thomas who's in our show
he was telling me from his research
their accent is so different to anything
in america
because it has so little influence and
there's so there's so little outside
influence that it's one of the closest
accents to early like colonial settlers
or something like that it's it's a treat
based on terrence and philip yeah that's
how i do that old-timey america's
terrence and philip hey buddy
uh in the show did you guys have a uh a
restaurant that specialized in crab and
ice cream
uh because i'm seeing on tangier island
google maps there's this crab house and
ice cream deck it's just crabs and ice
cream
oh my god if we could arrange a trip
after yeah after this
okay well yeah let's do it it's sinking
it is yeah we have to go soon um so so
we shot this show
in uh vancouver
and
i think from what i understand they
actually were looking at real islands
for us to film on
but they would have had to have got us
in a ferry every day it was it would
have been a freaking nightmare that
you're gonna have to get to it it would
have just been it was so religious so
they spit so what they did was they they
in the industry we call it when you
orbit in it
um
can you pronounce that correctly
you can do it again they hobbitoned it
oh
jacob please do your orcs just for a
second now which one is like i wanna
mount them
their fresh shoes
did a private screen in and elijah wood
was there
and he came up and he was like hey i was
having a cigarette so he was like hey i
really enjoy you the show and what
you're doing and stuff and i went
and i was like oh i saw you tweet about
it earlier and i said it to my family i
was like yo frodo diggs midnight mass
and my cast mates died inside a bit yeah
and and he just saw it you actually
called him frodo and he was like i heard
that when you were getting people to
crocket you orbited
it sounds like you've got you've got lag
that's a 10 year old accent yeah that's
how the american sounded back in the day
um anyway yeah so so the the set design
everyone they basically there were two
locations like prominently and
they just built that town
um
in a place called langley
it's like farm area it's like an hour
and a half drive from downtown
and yeah we we just had this town to
ourselves
and a lot of the interiors were built in
so a lot you know in a lot of other
things when you have an exterior and you
go through the door there's nothing
there and you just and then you cut to
your studio day where you walk through
the door and that's the set not on
midnight mass on a lot of those
locations when you open the door you go
in it's the house
so like my
i play the sheriff
my
uh
sheriff's office or whatever is at the
back of the grocery store
and you could physically be in the town
square walk
into the grocery store everything was
real although as you know from the tooth
story about my skittles all the produce
and and sweet candy was real
and you know you go through the back
door and you're straight into a
sheriff's prison
yeah no loading
you didn't have to crawl through a crack
yeah just
shimmy through it like yeah should be
through something
um but yeah
do you know why that decision was made
obviously i know that you didn't control
that choice but wouldn't that be really
no i did actually when i uh when i was
brought on board
has anyone seen lord of the rings
what did you say
they uh i'm i'm pretty sure it was yeah
it's expensive for sure but in the long
run
i think it probably was more cost
effective i guess to there are a lot of
interesting areas but what it gave mike
um and and michael fimignari who's the
dp uh what it gave him was this option
to go
why don't we just we can do a wanna here
we can start the scene
here
and we can just walk for two miles we
could do whatever we want and we don't
have to break camera and we control it
it's beautiful shots with like natural
lighting
yeah and they did a lot of it and
the long shots yeah that's something
that was so i was blown away by was yeah
it's because you guys had the town built
yeah like you were saying
there's shots and scenes where people
they're just walking through the town
all like the whole time yeah it's crazy
yeah it was wild man i've never
experienced something like that like
like i'm a big fan of technology and i'm
i would be i'm dying to do something
mandalorian-esque with the volume with
that kind of stage because that's
immersive shout out to unreal but this
shout's unreal but this is the shout out
to unreal
shout out to unreal
um
yeah this was like the practical version
of that so like when you're on there
like our green rooms were someone's
house
no no way
like they were just we were just they
would wherever we were sometimes our
green room was the school and we just
sat in the school real quick all of it
was it was a trip so
you were always there was never the
immersion was never broken and uh and
then there was a second location
because that was just the middle of the
farm and we're supposed to be an island
our coastal stuff was done on i think
it's called steveston beach any of the
canadian vancouver people will know it
and they built on that too
so we so like that's why
with the
start of episode two when the things
wash up and on the thing
and all those oh no better example than
that is when i think warren in the first
ep is on his bicycle and he's going
through all of that we that was us two
on the coast that was a second location
to look like the coastal bits
and because of covid
it was built
and then kovid stopped our production
the bastards no but obviously we went
through a pandemic and we didn't know
when we were going to come back and in
the five months that it took
the wet the weather elements
and the plants they had planted and all
the things they'd done overgrew
so we had this really weird thing when
we came back it looked so lived in
it was it was just like a happy accident
as bob ross would say so um
yeah so that's where we did all of that
was vancouver
one is looking at her phone the whole
island funnily enough because my mum
texted me
and said watching midnight mass right
now oh
she just finished episode three
it was relevant
yeah oh good one that has a location in
it too which
episode three has a location in it but
that isn't that without spoiling that
isn't crockett island
oh yeah oh
and that's
what again just how how talented so
these people are
it looks so legit what it's supposed to
be
vancouver
wow
yeah i mean the whole thing with it oh
go ahead jacob
yeah i was just saying like
you sort of mentioned like you talked
about immersion with the volume and
stuff it must have been like it's super
helpful for you as an actor just be in
this place that is all real around you
yeah 100 like
it
yeah and everyone kind of like something
weird did happen though
so
guys
so i didn't hang out with the cast a lot
right and it was covered probably they
wouldn't let you and they didn't like
your big [ __ ] nerd
because uh
yeah
whoa
i lost my my place and i'm stuttering
for some strange reason that's never
happened to me before but that's called
a nerd once
i'm not a nerd
um
they did all the church scenes i don't
i'm not in any church scenes right
and that was that church was
completely built that wasn't a location
or an existing building the inside was a
studio
as well it doubled up twice you could go
in but we actually had a studio version
of it too
so for about
i don't know how long i just wasn't at
work because it was time to do all the
church scenes and they were blocked
together as one big block
and by the time i came back
demolot were all best mates
and i was in one scene in the church i
come back and they're playing card games
they got private jokes
they got all these references
i don't know what's going on you were
the liv tyler of midnight mass what
happened to lift tyler
she
everyone
oh was together and they were all you
know best friends and then she went
shoes and stuff yeah yeah yeah i
remember yeah you talked about that
behind the scenes disc five even
there should have been one other person
who wasn't going to church but even they
were going to church without spoiling
anything so it was literally just me who
wasn't at the
at the church
um and then i was like oh [ __ ] y'all um
i i just i i just put headphones in i
was listening to mandalorian you
successfully i don't want to like just
interview here rahul but it is
interesting you successfully made a show
during
actually the height of code like the
months where it was even the worst um
pre-vaccine yeah yeah
uh and not many people did like i know
other people who were making shows up in
vancouver that got cancelled or took
hiatuses because um one of them was that
they were taking too many covert tests
yeah they overloaded it delayed um i had
a couple of friends who were out of work
like the question was just going to be
like
what what was it like filming that
during code what were the differences
for especially when some of those scenes
do have a lot of people thankfully you
have a lot of stuff in open air which i
feel like the crockett island south is
great for but some of them are a lot of
people in in the church or whatever
yeah well
yeah that's exactly what happened yeah
there was um
from being thorough one production
got shut down because they did too many
tests it got backlogged they overloaded
the lab and that was it they had to stop
because they couldn't safely test anyone
because they couldn't get through the
test results too many tests for being
too thorough so there was a sweet spot
of like how many do you do without
overloading a lab because every single
person on the production there's
hundreds of people need to be tested
every day they need to be accounted for
so
yeah while we were on a break
which was supposed to only be two weeks
because so what happened with us was
and i don't i mean i feel like i maybe
i've covered this in the previous ones
but we we did our table read
pre-pandemic
and then yeah
the day that i talk about this and then
on the day
okay i rarely listen
um this episode by the way is for my
brother-in-law who's going to be mad
happy that i've taken it over
and his favorite john's not talking yeah
i know i am looking over at the wave the
wavelengths of my recording and it's
very thick
in the beginning but now there's a lot
of blank spots and i'm really frustrated
about this one i recognize it it is this
is the worst episode you've ever seen
yeah
um yeah
anyway so so we were supposed to be gone
like day before filming it was march
13th covered hit and we all left it took
five months to figure out with the
governments and sag what the hell a show
during the pandemic looks like what is
it
no one's done it before right
so
um [ __ ] knew he was gonna do that i
mean i saw him backing up i was like i'm
being mocked it's happening everybody
jacob's doing my foot
my leg up on my desk because it's
comfortable and now jacob has done the
same but much sexier well in mind
they're a lot like sexier
you i'll make jacob yours is going to
make jacob feel bad where do you watch
it
so unfortunately a lot of people died
during the pandemic while we were
um trying to figure out what was going
on numbers obviously the hospitals
people's grandmas
i'm sorry
he's still drunk
because
why'd you laugh a lot he said people's
grandmas oh come on
during such a moment like this this is
serious you guys
unbelievable listen
terrible it is explains what the
pandemic was because
you know what inspired us to to go in
you asked like what what inspired us to
like
make this show and risk our lives like
we all risked our lives like ask that
why would you join the front line
for the arts yeah and be up there yeah
it's a lot and the truth of the matter
was what really inspired me because i
didn't think i wanted to do i don't know
i don't know how i felt was it wasn't
until
gal gadot's imagine
oh
yes really spoke to too old we all knew
yeah it was gonna be okay yeah uh come
honestly and then i was like you know
what
no we're gonna [ __ ] do this i can
imagine thank you
so much
[ __ ] actors are so embarrassing
sometimes jesus christ but honestly i
imagine it would have been real hard
that's the thing i imagine
is yeah it was it was really difficult
it was at a point where everyone was
like you remember when we thought your
amazon packages give you covid yeah
like my mum was watching every freaking
piece of mail that came because we
didn't know how contagious it was yeah
yeah
that's when we made the show so you can
imagine that our guidelines were mad
strict and and then
i remember there's a scene like you
mentioned a big church scene that i'm in
there were like 200 of us
and numbers spiked in canada in
vancouver particularly
and then it's in the trailer so i can i
can spoil it
i was one of the only people who for
most of the scene had four dudes on top
of him
breathing next to me
and we're just like
like this throughout a scene
and then obviously whatever and um
and no one got created yeah everyone was
that we did it and then because we did
it because we knew the industry was
watching us
it wrote the playbook
other shows around us like you said got
shut down and and they whatever but
midnight mass wrote the playbook and i
had texts from other people going we're
watching you we're waiting to see how
you lot do this
and it kind of became like a
a thing
um once we did it everyone else felt
confident that they could because but
it's expensive thank
you but again you know we're just you
know we didn't do it for the applause
yeah you know yeah not all heroes wear
capes right it's just so it's just you
doing big sacrifice yeah because of the
work you guys did setting the standard
for how to do a production in covid not
just a production how to behave during
covert how to make art journey
we have you to thank for melissa
mccarthy making this beautiful film
number two in the in the united states
on netflix
she plays opposite a bird
what is this now we all got a [ __ ]
look what have you done i didn't want to
look at the competition
netflix
everyone if you have to choose between
midnight mass and
the bird movie starling the starling i
just saw it
okay ign put a review up all right shall
i read the yeah i read the end
uh the styling review
for
bad
the starlight
starring melissa mccarthy is a story of
grief hampered by half measures and a
shield
of quirk
that's it let me just double check
something in the four okay still better
than midnight
mass
ign midnight
math uh we got a or
this is embarrassing
uh we got a nine amazing netflix's
midnight mass is another excellent story
from the king of horror mike flanagan oh
you know what this is backfired
i just saw i just scrolled past
something
i just there well this has backfired you
know i was just doing it because of
john's bit and then i just read among
this talented cast ronald coaly haunting
by mana is a standout as the township i
mean
what
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
nice but uh it is very good i recommend
everybody watch it obviously oh yeah
try not to spoil anything here um but
yeah i did definitely want to talk about
the island because it looks very pretty
um i mean vancouver it would be dope if
we could go to tangier island oh yeah i
wanted the first place we go to is that
crab ice cream place i do have yeah [ __ ]
yeah dude best plumber i do have grand
plans for this show as we continue that
eventually we can we can do travel vlog
stuff as an edition hell yeah
road
the other day because uh we were a ploy
to keep jacob away from his house for a
surprise oh my god i wanted to talk
about this yeah yeah go on um
and we yeah keep trying to have
conversations and then being like shut
up save it for the podcast
[Laughter]
we barely talk to each other yeah well
everything is shut up it sounds funny
jacob shut up and save it for the
podcast
i'm glad i didn't know about the snoop
dogg wine but yeah john was there a
particular part of uh kidnapping jacob
that you wanted to jump into
well i mean i think we kind of brushed
over
jacob's uh surprise party yeah uh on the
fun house podcast yeah so i saw that i
saw that went up and that both of you
were in it and then it mentioned it and
i was like oh oh doubling up on content
i want to give the good deeds keep
somebody save the good deeds yeah
well my favorite part was something
rahul pointed out after the surprise
was revealed
which is that the our con
was that we were all going to get
together jacob and i went to little
tokyo and bought gundams
with the intention of us hanging out
building gundams together and doing like
a vlog of it
um
and then we we brought him to his house
uh and suddenly he was surrounded by
people
it was go to little tokyo all meet up go
to little tokyo go gundam shopping bring
all of the gundams back to mine yep we
were then going to
build them
muck around and watch the first two
episodes of midnight
it was a lot yeah no but to be clear the
pitch of we're gonna go get gundams and
we're going to build them was a thing
that i asked to do before i knew that i
was a decoy for the surprise party so
that was a genuine request oh it was
then became a oh tara needs help keeping
jacob out of the house and then getting
him here at this time but then
we basically we we then came up with
this ruse that my apartment was going to
shut the power down at 6 00 p.m on a
saturday which is jacob
no it happened in his apartment building
recently
oh really yeah yeah it happened
yeah uh i had to do
something
on the internet or whatever i don't know
yes
i heard you yell my no it was my table
read for my new show that's why it was i
had to do a virtual table read in front
of
hulu executives
the day that they shut the power down to
the building and i was like which
they've done before was what you were
saying so i just pulled an example of
something that had happened recently in
rockefeller right yes the best lives are
steeped in truth that's true so thank
you but jacob being jacob was like we
were like so should we just carry on the
party at jacobs
and it's like yeah yeah so i was like
jacob i'd love to see your place can we
go do that and then he was like let me
text tara and i was like oh what if she
says no
so i got dressed
and did my hair
like i was going to a party
but only just going to j i could have
gone in the sweats but jacob doesn't
notice anything no he was so i didn't
notice that i also bought a giant
terrible box of white claws
what
remember we bought it yeah we brought it
in the car
and i didn't drive and
yeah anyway
and then we built it up is this going to
be this gundam party i'm so excited that
we've robbed jacob of a fantastic day
but i still intended
at one point uh during the party i
looked over and jacob was kind of
standing away from everyone just kind of
crying
uh and i think it was because
yeah he was yeah he was like oh god
tara killed it like it was such a big
surprise and jacob was so happy but
jacob was there any part of you that was
like
i thought we were gonna build gundams
i mean that was
listen i was very happy with what
actually happened but like up until i
opened the door i was a hundred percent
on board what we were gonna do
i was ready to like get in there i was
like this is gonna be a great day we can
still do it it's okay yeah
which was wonderful um i almost cracked
my head open on those stairs right
outside my front door
oh my god he did he was fell over
walking up there
also
that there was no parking available
around your street because there were so
many people who drove to yours
that you couldn't park that was so we
had to when we were trying to park was
that we were gonna pass like a really
recognizable friend's car like omar's
car or something or bruce yeah or bruce
who thankfully i think we passed yeah we
passed multiple cars i was like i'm
pretty sure that's bruce's yeah that's
because jacob i said jacob's in the
[ __ ] car
looking at the new gundam it was very
easy but bruce could have worked
on the box i was recording videos for
your tick tock that's what i was doing
yeah yeah yeah i twice i've had people
try to give me surprise parties and both
times i knew
because
i on a on my birthday i'm usually really
specific about what i want to do i'm
usually like here's what i would like to
do and so i'm just going to do that and
so then when i'm like i want to do this
and someone's like
you can't do that i'm like oh
and that's what he does every time i
spontaneously have decided that i would
like to have pizza for lunch and one
time blaine like flew to l.a to surprise
me
and had booked dinner for a bunch of
people at an italian restaurant and he
was like you can't don't have pizza for
lunch i wanted to have pizza with you
and i was like pizza twice i don't mind
having pizza twice if you want to have
pizza later we could have pizza on a
different day and he was like don't no
and then he texted bruce and was like
don't want to want to go you have pizza
for lunch and i was like it's my
birthday okay i'll see you in a few
hours but thank you
i mean like
it was helpful because like
i don't remember the last time i had any
kind of like actual birthday celebration
yeah i thought you were gonna say
friends
and yeah like maybe i'll like get drinks
or something or maybe i'll just like
like i never planned anything
it was pink pink
yeah i had a it was like ro rose gold
tara said specifically was i had a sash
on that said birthday [ __ ] on it it was
very pretty
and my tiara too i had a tiara it was a
whole thing
it was backwards the entire night oh no
was it yeah if you if you're uh if you
watch this podcast
should we use that for the thumbnail of
this
so what i is actually going to do for
the thumbnail this is pick a picture of
you looking really cool as sheriff
and then have pictures of us that i was
going to have each of us take looking up
at you like
that make it really cheesy so i'm going
to badly photoshop the three of us onto
an official midnight mass picture review
the only the only video or photo i have
from that night i haven't gathered any
from anybody else is this one of rahul
with a lightsaber oh my god
right outside the front door there's a
party happening inside and we were
outside by ourselves yeah jacob and i
snuck off the field so many times i
would look around and go where are jacob
and rahul and then i go upstairs and
they were like
in in jacob's office going oh my god
look at this gundam oh this was it took
me 20 hours to build
[Laughter]
it was looking at his helmet more than
once
yeah yeah it was like people was like oh
can we see your guns i'm like i guess my
favorite thing this like about that
video though was that rahul came back in
and was like oh jacob and i just filmed
a really cool lightsaber video and then
i watched it and i was expecting the two
of you fighting that maybe you'd like it
and that you'd choreograph but it was
just [ __ ] rahul spitting on my table
the only reason i didn't post that on
social media because i'm doing some
badass moves is because
my titties and my muffin top are just
messing around that's why the jedi's
wearing ropes sleight of hand all you
see is the lightsaber i wasn't looking
at anything no there's two what what
jacob what jedi's thick with loads of
c's
thick with loads of seats probably
i'm gonna go ahead and say uh probably
oppo rancisis jedi master on the did i
cancel how do we see this can you text
me a picture and i can hold it how do i
even spell that
o p p o r a and c yeah yes
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait i'm behind you what
let's do apple
oh my god
it is a lotta
o-p-p-o r-a-i-r-r-a-n-c-i-s-i-s
that thick
well he could be what is going on with
his face
okay
google just asked me did you mean
opportunities
literally any other word
yeah i mean he's a cool guy i like his
hair yeah he has a bun on top if you
like
him up he'll be nice and thick hang on
let me pull him over for the slinky
enough viewers real quick let me pull
him over here this is pictures oh yeah
alana yeah you got the
here we go
as a jedi this is the thickest jedi
that is absolutely how i look when i
wake up in the morning it's just this
oh my gosh i love him and his nails he's
on fleek oh yeah there he is
are you making it your background
oh i can i had just pulled it over so
that um i could show it to
the audience
but i can put him in the background
can you just make him background for me
he sent me john anonymous
yeah who the [ __ ] is that it looks like
from like the ewok adventure movie that
like
we watched it looks like one of the
koopas oh my god
what is that i think this is sanyasan
i think this is
from the
ewok adventures the second one with
wilford brimley
i've never seen the ewok adventures
really
i've never seen the holiday special and
i've never seen the ewok stuff well the
holiday special is worth watching while
drinking oh yeah you got a drink that's
like that's like a party that's you
watch that with a party have you watched
star wars visions either of you who i've
watched
it's me
that's how i look
you pick like
they would make toys of literally any
garbage character in star wars oh man
yeah but yeah i've watched star wars
visions a couple times now pretty much
oh i need to watch it
i've been i was up in ida wild with my
parents this weekend
it's really easy to get through every
they're all like 15 20 minutes no one
caught my joke what did you say
you said they would make what was it
what was that sentence they would make
garbage what garbage carrot garbage toy
toys about any star garbage star wars
character and i went ray nice oh i
missed that i saw your face very good i
knew you're no good
i don't get it it's fine don't worry
about it
say your whole name
ray skywalker there we go that's what i
wanted the nema post is that one galaxy
that was shoe college
no palpatine [ __ ] i don't know
i was really frustrated about daisy
ridley the evil version of her was a
dream
yeah
in all my media i would like doc link to
be present in old that's what i said
like as soon as the trailer came out and
people we talked about i'm like it's a
dream it's a dream scene cause it's damn
it yeah there's no way oh no jacob okay
this is the thing this is the only thing
that frustrates me about jacob is that
he's so non-confrontational
that he'll never argue with you
and i remember i sent him this theory
that rey
is like a clone or something uh that
palpatine made a bunch of clones or
something
and that the evil ray was another clone
and jacob was like yeah
maybe is there anything that you would
staunchly argue against jacob
uh uh hmm
depression
no what was that
fond of it actually oppression
depression oppression oh yeah
destiny
no i like it like i'll i'll defend kate
a little bit um
i'll take one i like kate i'll defend
kate a little bit i'm not wrong with you
because i'm too appointed there's parts
while i'll agree with you well [ __ ] off
all right we are all
pulling out a thread right now that we
shouldn't be you're right jacob once
admitted to us
that he has a recurring dream
what is your recurring dream jacob i
don't know if i said
did i say recurring yeah you said you've
had it multiple times
i know i've had dreams where i've gotten
like or i've like had to like
scream at somebody
i don't think there's anything specific
about it but i've had dreams where i'm
like letting loose
and i'm so and i'm like oh
one day and it could be the most
innocent thing
where we're like
yeah jacob's a sweet boy or whatever
and he just
and he unleashes on us and it cuts to
the core of us knows every one of our
deepest insecurities
and he just roasts all of us it's just a
word not put a word yeah he just looks
at me and goes
nose
and i'm like
and he knew
you have a beautiful nose yeah that'll
be like yeah i have a skull me going
into my surprise party that's all of you
when i finally
crack
but there was also another cool part of
that night um
where someone you know very easily
whisked you upstairs
yeah john yeah oh yeah who i'll do
anything for and then my we had you come
back down all the lights were off jewel
of the face was playing yeah that was
terrifying at the party you had a
lightsaber too lightsaber fight you
yeah that was my that was my gift to
jacob was i bought 20 lightsabers which
i filmed this one
do you know and for for anyone listening
what it looked like was that dope old
republic trailer with all the sith and
the [ __ ] all the sith light up in the
back of the ship
that was in my head i was drunk but like
that happened i was seeing the older
public trailer in my head
with the voiceover going yeah the dark
side will come whatever the [ __ ] it was
yeah
because john was like
let's go show me your lightsaber i was
like all right
you know what we never talked about
jacob your early birthday present was
when we were at the scum and villainy
cantina oh my god and strategically
sam sam whitworl was there and
made sure that it was jacob that the
free seat was next to yes we were there
sam sat next to jacob and sam
with mark noted on the podcast yeah
marvin yeah yeah
and it was jacob next to sam witwer
talking about clone wars dave filoni
darth maul solo the works like i was so
happy for jacob i was like he must be
[ __ ] loose
sam will do it forever and it's
wonderful because like for star wars
fans he he could not be more different
to harrison ford mm-hmm he will talk to
you about all of it forever and it's you
know better because he's a huge fan
himself yeah right yeah like sam
whoever's been on my radar since like i
played force unleashed in 2008.
yeah stalking like
i always forget he's starkiller first
before darth maul yeah yeah like that i
was gonna put all aside just like hey
sam i loved you and stephen king's the
mist
he got stabbed by a butcher knife
i know him from battlestar galactica
that's how i first started either wow
that's so weird yeah he gets eaten by a
praying mantis it would all be stuff
that i've seen before i knew sam
who um
fosters dogs so most of our relationship
is him sending me pictures of his foster
dogs who are all absolutely wonderful
he's got three of them right well i
think it's like in force unleashed it's
just his face
and like it's it just looks like him it
sounds like him so it's like that yeah
but
male video game protagonist that's true
shepard sort of looks like sam whitwoer
just naturally
i couldn't make a character in mass
effect andromeda that i didn't look like
george lopez
[Laughter]
lopez i want to get these references
beverly hills chihuahua nope
shark boy lava girl
that's a classic
but yeah it was a it was a fun day we
should still go to a little tokyo at
some point oh yeah out oh yeah it was
like the party itself was like it was so
fun it was a good time it was a really
you got that you got that good jacob
drunk where at the end of the night you
were on a couch just like
just like
that [ __ ] one thing if i had to
be annoyed about any of it
is when there's always some [ __ ] [ __ ]
right who gets a guitar out yeah and
starts [ __ ] holding people hostage
with playing guitar
if anybody didn't [ __ ] ask just
showing the [ __ ] off
and i don't know why tara invited them
um
it was wrong everybody was ruffled i had
this moment
was on the drums too tara was playing
drums and rahul was playing guitar and i
was sitting next to elise
and a woman i don't know started singing
and i was just like
this is the most la party i've ever been
to oh yeah that was a lady i didn't know
started to sing the lyrics of the song i
was playing when did this happen oh my
what have we done
there were multiple guitars at one point
yes they were and then then somebody
started playing piano and i was like
jesus [ __ ] christ los angeles i swear
to god
oh my god tara's chair is actually a
cajon that she could play with her hands
i actually played the drums too but what
i did was i went and i closed the door
and i played them very lightly
[Music]
i'll hear the door unlocking and i'm
like
put all the sticks away and then i run
out of rocks and go upstairs and start
putting models together be okay
yeah i feel like i feel like tara would
walk in and jacob's been doing the air
version of it though
so he was there shirtless and he's like
i'm naked
but he dared not actually make contact
with the sticks yeah yeah i don't want
to besmirch it with my lack of talent
no but you think it's all jacob i didn't
know my one thing about the party yeah
uh
was and it was a great reveal the whole
lightsaber thing but in my mind when i
bought it
and this is the whole you know the the
classic projecting your autobiography on
other people
um in my mind i was like everyone will
have a lightsaber and everyone
will just have so much fun play fighting
with each other
there wasn't enough space for that
well there wasn't enough space but also
i'm pretty sure no one
like no
very few adults still want to do that
yeah and so it's like me jacob and rahul
like running around like fighting and
everyone is just kind of standing there
with lightsabers like john do you
remember do you remember when jacob
decided that the lightsabers you got him
were insufficient for what he wanted to
do
jacob goes upstairs and grabs his super
to the one in that video the super duper
one me john and jacob are mucking around
while the adults are now going back to
like yeah so anyways
yeah
and me and jacob jacob was on the
staircase going
you know i have the high ground and i
was good there you underestimate my
power
oh don't forget remember i blew up my
birthday candles
you did oh yeah that was that was really
cool what did he do i mean like a
samurai he swiped a lightsaber across
and put out both candles
you didn't see that there was no i must
have been having a cigarette yeah i'll
find the video of it yeah i only saw it
because you put it on your instagram
story yeah i think uh jen
um recorded a video a very good video of
me watching how many candles twirling
the lightsaber and then
and then putting it away number it was a
few just two it was just two just like a
three and a zero
it was thirty yeah well he's two there
he turned thirty ruffle
happy birthday
thirty five your birthday was actually
on tuesday wasn't it
yeah thursday it was wait are you elite
wait you're a libra
brother you are a [ __ ] yeah
i can't remember what date it is what's
your rising sign
what's that
it's my writing
posted something the other day that was
like hey all my friends who know they're
like three
fate phases i was like what is this how
do i figure that out i don't know what
any of this means i don't know what that
is
what's your star sign
i'm a cusp taurus
i'm a classic logo
because taurus means i'm close to the
other sign or something well this is a
very similar birthday and they replied
with that and i was like okay obviously
the predictable comments are star signs
but there will be people there that are
like oh yeah astrology quite well i do
think i think
of whatever but like
[Laughter]
says my scorpio tattoo um but but but
if you're a taurus and you're a virgo
and you're a virgo and i'm a scorpio
people who like astrology will know that
this is a very compatible podcast
i think scorpio is not a real sign
yeah
it is it's in november it sounds that's
that's way cooler
so you know that you're you you know
enough to say that you're a taurus cusp
but doesn't know that scorpio
i'm a curse of taurus and my rising
sinus cancer you called yourself out
when you went
[Music]
i don't know what it is but i i looked
it up and i had to put in the exact time
that i was born whoa what at like 3 p.m
i think
how do you do it i calculate your rising
sign okay yeah oh what okay okay
it wants me to sign up
no i got it i got it got it
why does it need my name
do you know what time you were born i
don't know yeah i do three i was born at
3 p.m
november in australia
1980 this is interesting because i have
to put in the country i was born in is
it gonna ask me for the time zone i was
born in or does that not matter
because 3 41 a.m i don't know my legs
it's three something
okay here's mine ready calculate
interesting what the [ __ ] you have
ascendant in libra yeah capricorn i'm a
taurus i'm a taurus ascendant
pisces ascendant i'm sorry whoa the it
has your moon the moon yeah
cancer my moon and cancer pisces is
synonymous i'm moon in scorpio
and i get five stars for my personality
report so
i think we all do and it's 15 bucks
my personality is five stars and it
wants fifteen dollars to find out why
i'm a five star oh yeah because i guess
taurus is april 21st through may 21st so
i am a cusp taurus because i'm the first
day
yes you're only cosplaying for the first
day on the last day so i'm class virgo
because i'm the first day of virgo
before music oh i can brag about it
let's just debunk something right now
alana you've got the virgo obviously so
as jacob could you read with the picture
have you got the picture of some person
chilling
and it says virgo um yeah
yeah can you read that little sentence
out zodiac and we'll decide if it's both
you and jake
peace loving helpful dutiful and hard
working order must be around them
further people are charming and know how
to handle money
i think the money thing's right
you're both very good
yeah beautiful and hard working and i
think i'm helpful i don't know about
peace loving
john what's yours say mine makes no i
don't even know what this means it says
they love the property
unlike the oh no wait i think it's
because i'm an earth sign they love the
property of being an earth sign but
unlike the other two earth signs virgo
and capricorn they buy things to use
them because they are connoisseurs
i'd say you're materialistic john i had
a friend who this weekend texted me and
was like i started to collect uh retro
video games and i was like you're not
the first friend who said this to me in
the last couple of years you know how
long it's a slippery slope
yeah slippery slope i was like i look
forward to that not being a thing in
three months
george
was that on your
tour uh taurus
tourists yeah i have something about
buying things because i'm a connoisseur
what's this
scorpio
kind reliable and hard working that's
how you can define scorpio scorpio looks
outwardly calm but is dynamic friendly
and has a keen intelligence
do i look calm it's [ __ ]
i don't buy a lot of matt
i'm a [ __ ] message
i'm a moon i'm a moon in cancer i got
moon and cancer what does what is your
kind of moon in scorpio which means i
don't i already killed my page
yeah let's let's [ __ ] close this page
that's not true i just don't have many
it's not the same it's not like
sagittarius
i've got a moon sagittarius sagittarius
is a fire sign and it's not a
particularly sensitive sign i'm mad
sensitive
i'm one of the most sensitive have you
not seen my twitter
some prick
in the middle of nowhere 12 year old
who's got an egg
right could say
in a sea of compliments goes
don't like your face
and i have to go out of my way to
humiliate them quote them there was one
time
talking about something that you had
worked on and you you had a criticism of
it and i agreed with your criticism and
you went well um actually i thought that
and i was like i'm agreeing with you
[Laughter]
it's validating you
you're supposed to go
no no it's perfect
i was like yeah no that is a good point
and because of this and then you were
like ah
have you considered this about
very strong do you know what you did
right it's the equivalent of say someone
saying
yeah my dick's tiny and then that person
going yeah and then you go what and they
go well i'm agreeing with you no you
weren't saying it to fish for
compliments it was genuine i'm always
fishing for compliments that's true
it he's got us right in his hand right
now
to reel it in yeah
i i want john to i want to pay for
john's um personality report for fifteen
bucks yeah so we can be
finally a five star and we can read it
we can read it on the next is it is the
myers-briggs thing [ __ ]
so i actually use my springs um
all the time uh so it they're all
[ __ ] is this short um because you
also answer them with like a ton of bias
and it depends what day you can have
yeah every time i've taken it yeah um i
feel like my my myers-briggs is pretty
accurate to to
my personality but i use them all the
time when uh developing characters uh
mayas is really helpful for figuring out
what someone is like thinking and how
they would react and like it's
very very helpful
um i'm an infj
yeah i don't remember what mine was i
didn't i don't know okay so i took mine
and you know how they're each one
there's like eight characters because
each one's on a sliding scale the four
number or the four letters
yeah my
i was in the middle of every single one
wow
so it gave me i think it said intp but
it was like
each one was like a percent like one
percent off the middle so if you didn't
want a different one
the thing that got me about mine is that
it's an infj
which is i don't know what these
abbreviations are
infj is introverted intuitive feeling
and judging but the way that they
categorize it is that it's the
charitable personality it's somebody who
is very driven by doing a lot of charity
well that's bollocks because you don't
[ __ ] do anything for charities
literally never
um
i in the last 24 hours i've done three
charity campaigns and it's like a
compulsion
um and like that made me go oh [ __ ] like
for them to get that based on garbage
answers that i put in for that to be
that accurate felt felt very strange but
then also hitler is an infj the charity
personality
what
what
about that alana you forwarded this to
me
yeah probably didn't you make me do this
yeah i mean you're all wonderful well
didn't i have the attention seeker or
whatever you did
yes you had the performer
the performer yeah
so again i think they're all pretty much
garbage but it is intj i actually
learned about that through okay cupid
because before okcupid was like more
streamlined
uh they the way they originally went
viral was they had it was basically a
myers-briggs test but it was all
spun around like kind of
naughty dating questions
and it would tell you your dating
personality but it was just myers-briggs
um hey talking about personalities i
haven't watched it or i think i watched
half an
hour of it but netflix has a show called
split personalities
this guy
who had multiple personality
disorder i think split with james
and the guy's scottish no so he's it's
the dude in 1977
i think he was um sexually assaulting
campus b i don't
but he had 16 personalities and was and
they were trying to decide whether or
not he was clinically guilt yeah and
i only watched a bit before i passed out
but it's like apparently
it was very boring
apparently like his brain waves changed
with his characters so
i don't know yeah i want to watch it all
but it's about multiple personalities
super interesting
and you should also watch the starling
and also midnight mass or as we like no
the starling night ass knight x
so there was a cast picture and i think
someone put midnight
mass holes or whatever it was midnight
marsh holes very good yeah i saw a night
ass cause like i had um
[Music]
like the picture of the poster open on
my phone and my cat came in like late on
it and i just saw night ass i'm like
that's really funny kate siegel texted
me this today which she found on the
internet which was just says midnight
bass and i don't know if you can see
they've photoshopped his face
very good
he's so good in the show i mean you're
great at the show but he's awesome no
yeah he's
i think you should get an oscar
make it out i want a um
a grammy for my performance
for singing in the choir yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean all those beautiful hymns
that are in the soundtrack that's raffle
mike's on one of them for real mike is
one of them yeah which one is that you
know which is the choir boy right yeah
he is on
the last
him in the show
[ __ ] hell the last of him in the show
i believe mike mike is one of the
prominent voices he's the one doing the
high soprano yeah
um before we wrap up and he's in the
show he's in the show twice
yeah sorry go ahead we just talked about
that's how we talk to each other a
lot i like it
this one i know the reviews of this one
this one is not enough john roll was
[ __ ] talking over everyone about his
stupid [ __ ] show stupid bastard
too much you say you're insecure
no that's all right
um
yeah the next episode will be out on
it'll be the first of november
which is exciting because we are still a
monthly podcast everybody um yeah we're
getting way more views on youtube and we
have been premiering the show so
it goes live at the same time make sure
i'll jump in the chat again um did
anyone else have anything else they
wanted to to share before we before we
close it out
i would like you lot to choose my dinner
tonight which fast food restaurant
should i order from because i've not
eaten yet hmm what's open
are you waiting for everything show us
that snoop dogg is this a sponsorship
jacob i feel like we should yeah what's
the [ __ ] i wish this is actually
delicious is it
is it snoop dogg's actual wine
i guess so 19 crimes cali rose
okay snoop dogg wine 19 crimes snoop
dogg's very own red wine hit shelves
um
19 crimes is a brand that's teamed up
with snoop dogg to release a limited
californian that has arrived on oh this
is a new zealand basement hold on a
minute john you didn't tell us what an
amish russian was or whatever oh yeah oh
amish white uh it's a white russian boat
with oat milk
oh
so that i don't get uh you're lactose
intolerant
no i just like the taste of votes
oh yeah i actually agree with you
yeah
yeah i like it i'm not doing it you know
for health or hipster reasons i just
really like oats almond milk tastes like
uh corpse [ __ ]
yeah
well also if you're drinking the silk i
i tried the silk
oat milk and it tasted exactly the same
as the silk almond milk because
they're those milks are mostly just soy
and then they sprinkle in some almonds
or oats it's like all the same stuff but
uh for those of you that are lactose
intolerant i highly suggest uh oat milk
uh because
and justin uh an editor at funhouse
turned me onto this it's the only milk
alternative that keeps that creaminess
yeah it's so kind of like when you're
when you're putting in coffee it's you
still get that creamy coffee so i
actually really liked oat milk in my
peachy tips and the tea i actually have
you tried i know you did yeah i did it
on accident one time it's nice and then
i was like this is good it's good yeah i
like it it is good and i actually like
oatmeal with cereal like i wouldn't have
like almond milk with cereal in another
[ __ ] disgusting but oat milk is
i i oat milk's the truth i like nut milk
yeah who's not
yeah
anyways
yeah
oh my god alrighty everybody thank you
so much for listening to episode 3 of
idiots and abroad jacob where can
everybody find you
everybody can find me at funhouse and on
twitch fun house on youtube twitch jacob
full that's where i'm doing my stuff
jacob full like wonderful yes exactly
you're beautiful
there you go john how about you what are
you up to
um i'm streaming on twitch i'm probably
going to make a youtube video in the
next year probably
um and everybody go check out
pizzapotty.com i paid a designer way too
much money to make a new logo
uh and i'm really just trying to get a
return on that investment so please
uh go there they're tiny arm socks
i want to buy your merch john i want to
buy your machine to write it down it's
very cool what is it
pizzaposse.com this is a great website
pizza thank you
posse i made it myself using a square
space cheering myself
dude this is really cool
it's legit i got it bookmarked i i just
i i've always felt that i'm good at
finding good artists so i just i just
browse by hands and stuff and then i say
hey can i pay you to make a design that
has a pizza
i'm not i'm not sucking you off oh these
t-shirts are great yeah thank you
i want to buy it oh you gave me that one
the girl one
oh yeah yeah yeah
it shrunk john it shrunk well
i have the maybe you maybe you inflated
i value my pizza by pizza thrown one
that has the the dick on it
i got the og
i didn't realize that yeah a little uh
easter egg the pizza king shirt his
intestines are falling out of his chest
or out of his stomach but it 100 just
looks like a dick a big dick wait i'm on
that one oh my god it does
i like the tie-dye beanie the most i
think
yeah
which one do you like pizza party
tie-dye beanie
that's super cute
i'm gonna buy this pizza king dick one
now
[Laughter]
it's another oh you're gonna buy it
it's a really nice shirt
she just got real chatty lately
just so you guys know
this is a tip uh for the clothes because
they are print on demand heat is the
enemy of print-on-demand shirts gotcha
so if you can hang dry
uh or turn the shirt inside out when you
wash it so i didn't get it you [ __ ] i
told you i shrunk it
you said inflated inflated yeah
like water weight because of your period
yeah
trying to make me act like it was my
fault i put it in the dryer and a bit
shrunk well he didn't say it you wanted
it buy you a bigger one
huh
you want to buy you a bigger one no no
i'm buying it i want to support you bro
i love you i'm gonna
a bunch of t-shirts i want them uh
raffle what are you up to where can
people find you what are you doing i'm
an employee bro
you're not
i'm well i ain't plugging it oh okay
all right yeah i'm working on i'm
working on some thing whatever um but um
yeah i'm on twitter and instagram and
that uh and tick tock roll cody13
sometimes on tick tock but yeah midnight
mass is
my favorite thing i've ever made uh i've
been a part of and um yeah so i'm just
enjoying
18 months i don't know two years
november 2019 is when i was brought on
so
wow finally seeing two years people so
that's what i'm going to be doing but
actually i want to use my plug okay to
say something okay
[ __ ] keep assuming that either
john jacob or myself came up with the
title of the show and i want it on
record can we who came up with uh all of
this and the titles all point at them
so it was nobody rahul and john
so we've ruled out two of us yeah
definitely not me no thank you rahul
yeah it does happen a lot with stuff
that i if i concept that people tend to
just be like oh i bet john came up with
the name which again the name is still
just stolen from ricky gervais
yeah yeah but it was it was my pitch
but we're having a great time i love you
all oh yeah and this is wonderful
podcast title all of it
i got nothing to do with it
yeah thank you tori our building manager
at funhouse came up he's like oh yeah
like i watched your guy your podcast was
so good i was like it felt kind of
strange i'm like alana does all the work
like so that's that's
watching it
yeah you know i've been a producer for a
long time which means that i think oh
this group of people is going to be
fantastic and i know to like how to do
that but yeah i just sit here like we're
all together that's against like the
post stuff
no but you do all that you have all the
uploads and the editing and make sure it
goes out to apple yeah we don't do any
of that thank you
i wouldn't do any of it otherwise yeah i
would not do if you asked anything other
of me and too much effort we do think
that we'll be able to do the show in
person um
in maybe november or december but i'm
still figuring that out
because there will be room for that to
happen so we'll see how it goes
no you're wrong we'll tell you when we
end the recording
i don't know what what i want to do for
christmas this year you know thought
about going to new york
yeah
but my stepdad really wants to do it
like we should go tangier new york when
it snows it's it's just all the snow is
black because it's covered in dirt
yeah but you know again as an australian
all of your christmases
are summer which i love but if i can't
go home
then why not do the christmas i never
had
which is like the idea did you ever have
a big bear yeah it did snow but i mean
like in terms of the all the movies are
like show you that new york christmas
but i shouldn't do it because my stepdad
really wants to and
and doesn't want to travel again beyond
the new york what about india
um
i guess what's christmas like in india
ignorant
well yeah i don't know that's why can
you guide us around rahul yeah because
you're prompted
[Music]
google question about tangier island
uh will tangier be saved and patricia
smead says you can't fight mother nature
it's inevitable damn dog makes you think
also
talking about sinking i'll leave you
with this did you know they're building
the titanic again it comes out next year
not the i mean the ship they're
rebuilding
titanic ii
wow that who would i was researching
my new role i was researching for a new
role about both
it's it it's tiny it's an infant
compared to the that's true that exists
now yeah eight notes it's the whitest
thing i've ever heard that they're gonna
recreate it
right and they're gonna set sail i'm not
saying i want it to sink because that's
a horrible thing to wish upon it but the
whoever goes on that maiden voyage it's
going to do the same route
if it [ __ ] hits an iceberg by
accident and they [ __ ] sink i am
going to crack the [ __ ] up you do not
get oh my god
you do not get my sympathy if you
mimicked it and it did the same [ __ ]
lightning strikes twice we like
progressed in terms of what we can do
with um
like both hardware technology now and
there are they actually yeah i mean it's
yeah it's not gonna happen the inside's
gonna be all state of the art and stuff
what's gonna happen is everybody on it's
gonna get covered they're not gonna be
able to get off for like six months
they'll be abandoned
everyone's gonna have phones
yeah they'll be live
yeah
streaming
well everybody's gonna think it's just
gonna look like the movie they'll be
doing the the someone instead of like an
actual um
violinist
uh
playing someone could just hold their
phone up and do that
there's gonna be a line at the front of
the boat like the whole time
oh people do with the
yeah you're right yeah
[ __ ] influences man i i can't hear
anything right at all it was edited out
which is for the best because i would
get copyright claim for that real quick
how quick i put like five seconds yeah
like five seconds no it means it's real
fast
really himself oh yeah oh what if i sing
it that should be fine just you can't be
a pitch
[Music]
copy i'm always playing with that that
limit
with videos and stuff i snuck in the
parade song from the end of phantom
menace
yeah
because
it was a gta and lindsay's like jacob's
here and i just put like
um thank you all for watching next
episode like i said will be up
on the
1st of november because this is a
monthly podcast we upload on the first
monday of every single month we will see
you then
[ __ ] weirdo